Sharon and Ozzy Osbourne are ending
their 33 year marriage and more
information is coming to light about his
alleged affair a source tells ET all the
chatter is very hard on this close-knit
family Sharon understandably took today
off we are sending all of our love to
her and to her family and we ask that
you do the same source tells ET Sharon
discovered Ozzy had become too close to
a woman named Michelle Pugh the 45 year
old is a hair stylist to the stars and
working as a colorist at celeb hot spot
salon mesh the upscale Beverly Hills
salon caters to clients like Paltrow
Cameron Diaz and the Kardashians to name
a few and Ozzy's family goes there too
Michelle and Ozzy's relationship had
definitely raised eyebrows quote it was
known in the salon that they were a
little too close Michelle is super into
rock and metal music so they bonded over
that Kelly Osbourne had just gotten her
hair done there a source close to the
Osbourne's tells auntie all of this has
been very hard on the family
especially Kelly quote there are
concerns that Ozzy will be lost without
Sharon because he relies on her for
everything